jour en jour je vous le disais la
violence des combats s'accentue en
ukraine après des combats donc dans les
environs la kiev la capitale est presque
encerclé totalement par l'armée russe la
résistance ukrainienne garde encore la
maîtrise du terrain notamment au nord
kiev où la résistance donc s'organise de
toute part comment les habitants font
face à cette guerre on va tenter d'en
savoir un peu plus avec notre invité
bonjour andriy bonjour vous êtes
ukrainien donc vous habitez à kiev
pouvez vous nous décrire tout d'abord la
situation là vous vous trouvez et votre
quotidien à l'heure actuel andry
jeu oui j'ai su que j ai bien j'assume
craignant j'ai dit presque au centre de
la ville donc la ville est bloquée
presque du côté de nord est
on essaie de le bloquer aux côtés du sud
mais les magasins les supermarchés sont
les petits magasins ne sont pas ouverts
à les supermarchés sont ouverts il ya
encore des produits d'alimentation
donc c'est assez calme ici à kiev
malgré certaines à certaines disent ils
que la russie lance sur kiev mais notre
système de défense aérienne plus ou
moins efficaces ici mais il y avait des
missiles qui a frappé au bâtiment andré
on imagine que vous faites partie comme
tous les hommes ukrainien vous avez été
mobilisés après la décision de
mobilisation générale prise par le
président ukrainien zelensky on imagine
que vous avez pris les armes vous voulez
vous aller vous allez le faire
oui j'ai appelé notre commissariat on
m'a dit que lui il ya plein d un très
grand de ce qu'
il ya un grand réserve et puisque je
n'ai pas de de l'expérience
militaires des combats donc je suis en
grande réserve et moi j'ai du temps pour
m'occuper de volontaires donc moi je
suis volontaire j'ai aide aux
soldats qui défend dans notre ville
parce qu'ils ont un souci comme l'eau
potable
quelques produits d'alimentation les
chaussettes tout ça
moi j'ai organisé quelques gens et on
est les fournitures ici sur les points
de blocage
landry est peut-être un mot également
avec vous imagine que vous avez de la
famille est ce que votre famille a pu
quitter les zones de combat peut être
vers d'autres pays frontaliers comme
c'est le cas pour de nombreux ukrainiens
mes parents restent encore à kiev mais
qui ce soit la décision de quitter la
ville heureusement ils pourront la
partie sud à la campagne à 150
kilomètres de kiev et on faire de trajet
demain moi je suis divorcée même à ex
femme il est aussi hors de la ville
ma soeur avec ses deux petits enfants
ont quitté kiev et ils sont maintenant
aux régions du mythe qui c'est la partie
ouest de l'ukraine mais il reste
un mois également avec vous en dry
peut-être de de ce que vous attendez
vous de dd pays occidentaux comment les
pays occidentaux on a vu les livraisons
d'armes notamment décider comment les
qu'est ce que vous attendez de ces pays
occidentaux
nous moi je lis les actualités je vois
qu'il ya les fournitures de l'armement
et hier on a vu qu'il y avait beaucoup
des
avions qui font les bombardements des
grands villes comme cartier charlie qui
soumet il était abattu même aujourd'hui
avait deux ou trois avions russes qui
étaient abattus aussi je pense que c'est
un c c'est armés qui étaient les prêts
par les pays occidentaux mais autrement
nous
nos souffrons beaucoup nos grands villes
comme kharkiv comme j'ai déjà dit il
souffre beaucoup des missiles et des
avions
militaires russes et c'est ce que je
voudrais encore proclamé que le débat
que nous demandons tous les ukrainiens
civile de fermer notre ciel
ce qu'on demande aux pays hôtes d'autant
de fermer le ciel parce qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup des gens civile qui
souffre et il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
morts entre la population civile parce
qu'ils font les bombardements des
banlieues et des quartiers où il ya les
grands maisons à plusieurs étages et où
il y a beaucoup de populations
c'est quelque chose que vous avez pu
constater vous des bombardements de
l'armée russe sur des habitations
civiles notamment il ya beaucoup de
d'accusation en ce sens qui pointe la
russie qui est accusée de bombarder des
civils c'est quelque chose vous avez pu
voir vous
oui je peux le constater non seulement
de prendre des actualités mais à côté de
moi à la distance à peu près 2 3 km une
missile russe a frappé le bâtiment de
cinq étages
et sept missiles est entré au milieu de
bâtiments mais heureusement il n'y avait
pas des morts il y avait seulement les
quelques gens qui étaient blessés
dernièrement ce milieu il y avait des
enfants
dernière question avec vous en deuil
quels rapports vous entretenez vous avec
avec avec la russie on sait que
l'ukraine et la russie se sont dopés
historiquement proche de peut placer à
ses proches qu'elle quel regard vous
portez sur sur la russie sur et sur les
russes de manière plus générale
vraiment ici on les déteste on les bts
mois chez g les parents
comment
la soeur la soeur de mon père
donc j'ai aussi la famille dans les rues
6 et 11 coups j'étais avant que facebook
n'était pas bloquée j'étais en contacts
avaient eu avec eux pour leur donner des
informations mais il me comprend mais
mes parents me comprends mais il ya
beaucoup beaucoup des gens en russie qui
ne comprennent rien et ils veulent cette
guerre ils veulent tuer les ukrainiens
ils veulent tuer les civils parce qu'ils
pensent que nous sommes des nazis ici et
c'est vraiment quelque chose de bizarre
parce qu'il ne donne pas là parce que la
possibilité d'évacuer les gens
des points de combat et c'est ce qu'on
demande aussi aux peut-être croire ou
jours donc d'essayer organisé ces
corridors verts pour les
pour les civils car pour ceux qui
veulent quitter les points de combat
parce que moi j'ai pris la décision de
rester jusqu'à la fin ici
merci beaucoup andry pour votre
témoignage très fort et très poignant et
pour cet éclairage sur le quotidien très
tragique on l'aura compris des des
civils comme vous qui sont qui sont
encore à kiev notamment encore merci à
vous d'avoir répondu aux questions de
france 24